so you guys hear about this you heard
about the Kentucky Derby controversy
right if you didn't if you didn't hear
about it let me explain and now I I
should say I know nothing about horse
racing whatsoever I watch I'll watch the
Belmont if there's a Triple Crown at
stake so I watch maybe three and a half
minutes of horse racing per decade or so
but still I can you know I can read
headlines and so if you read headlines
that makes you an expert these days if
you didn't know so I'm an expert based
on the headlines I've read and so let me
let me explain this to you here's what
happened this one horse won the race
right there the first horse won but then
they were like oh no the first horse
didn't win the second horse won't won
and so the second horse was like oh
sweet and but the first horse said no
that's that's that's BS man
and a lot of people a lot of other
people said oh no I disagree with this
and then but then some other people also
said no I agree I think it's the right
call and then there are other people who
said I can see both sides of it and and
that's what that's that's that's the
gist of it sorry to get technical on you
you know I the horse racing industry we
tend to forget that novices don't know
all the minutiae so we'll kind of speak
technically so I apology I didn't lose
you there in explaining it so there you
go that was my horse-racing commentary
for the day check back tomorrow for some
more well we've got a lot we need to
talk about today but before we get there
you know it's summer and the only thing
more annoying than the winning horse at
the Kentucky Derby having his victory
stolen from him is flies and other
insects that are buzzing around your
home and you know when you think about
flies who knows where a fly was last
well you can think about where flies
tend to tend to hover a garbage and that
sort of thing and then if one lands on
your food on your hamburger now you've
got a piece of all that stuff in your
hamburger so that's pretty disgusting so
we'd like to thank our sponsors over a
dynatrap dynatrap is the leading
manufacturer of outdoor mosquito and
insect traps and now they've come up
with a solution for indoor pests as well
the dynatrap fly light so the dynatrap
fly light works day and night to attract
and entrap flies fruit flies mosquitoes
other pesky insects and i got to tell
you it really works I've been you know
these these
you know you those those fly strips and
everything that people use or that's
like dangling down that plastic that
people use the old-school way of doing
it and then you run into it accidentally
and you've got dead flies wrapped around
your face it's happened to me
well the dynatrap fly light is not like
that it looks like a subtle nightlight
that you plug in and it's out of the way
and it takes care of the problem trust
me I've been using this especially for
mosquitos I mosquitoes are very
attracted to me personally so I get bit
up my people like having me around
because I tend to attract all the
mosquitoes I don't want to be either
want the thing that attracts mosquitoes
I want to have the Dyna the dynatrap fly
light that does that for me and I've
been using it and just insane number of
insects I've been caught in that thing
and it really takes care of the problem
so get yours at dynatrap dot-com
that's Dyn ATR AP comm enter the promo
code remember to do this promo code
walsh and receive 15% off any of their
products dynatrap the safe silent and
simple solution to household insect
control terrorists in the Gaza Strip
fired over 700 rockets at Israel at
civilian targets in Israel over the
weekend many of them were intercepted
many of the Rockets were but many of
them also hit Israel responded and as
Israel responded to the attack some
Democrats in Congress as you have come
to expect came out in support of the
terrorists who fired the rockets
initially now you could probably guess
who the people are who came out in
support of the terrorists first one is
Ilhan omar who tweeted and said how many
more protesters must be shot rockets
must be fired and little kids must be
killed until the endless cycle of
violence ends well if you want to know
how many Rockets you know how many more
Rockets have to be fired well then maybe
ask the people who fired the rockets in
the first place
said she says the status quo of
occupation humanitarian crisis in Gaza
is unsustained unsustainable only real
justice can bring about security and
lasting peace but to me that was not
nearly as concerning as the tweet that
was sent by
Rashidah Talib congresswoman from
Michigan and she's an American
congresswoman allegedly here's what she
said now listen to this
she said when will the world stop
dehumanizing our Palestinian people who
just want to be free headlines like this
and she oh she's reacting to a headline
in the New York Times and I think it's
New York Times headlines like this and
framing it in this way just feeds into
the continued lack of responsibility on
Israel who unjustly oppressed and target
Palestinian children and families all
right let me I'll go back to that first
sentence because that's really the only
sentence that matters here she says when
will the world stop dehumanizing our
Palestinian people who just want to be
free what our Palestinian people our now
we're told that it's a racist smear to
accuse Muslim politicians of dual
loyalty and I agree that if you were to
it would be a smear to accuse a Muslim
politician of dual loyalty just because
she's a Muslim that would be a smear but
if she advertises her dual loyalty if
she comes out and says it which is what
she just did here our Palestinian people
um well then it's not a smear it's just
an observation that's all and actually
maybe I should back up for a minute
because no I I don't think that to Labe
it has dual loyalty because there's no
evidence at all that she's loyal to
America in the first place so I think
I'm more accusing her of having sole
loyalty to her Palestinian people that's
what she just said she said she said
well they're my people this is I mean
that is really really concerning
you know I it's it's I don't think it's
like a matter of semantics here yeah
it's just one word but that's a really
important word because that is a word
that expresses who your loyalties lie
with who
who you identify yourself with and I
don't think it's too much to ask that if
you're a politician in America and
you're a representative of American
citizens
whenever you refer to our people you
should be talking about Americans or
even more specifically the the American
citizens who elected you and who you
represent I think she needs to be
investigated for this and I'm serious if
she was a if she was a civilian I mean
it would be one thing there are plenty
of idiots on Twitter who are cheering on
terrorists and they're allowed to do
that I think it's I think it's vile and
stupid but they're allowed to do it if
you're a member of the US Congress and
you're referring to non Americans as
your people that raises some very
serious questions your sole loyalty as
in as a representative as a member of
the US government needs to be with
America I mean do you think someone
could get a job like at the NSA if they
went around saying stuff like this
you think if in the interview process at
the NSA you were to refer to my
Palestinian people you think you'd get
the job no there's no way if you're
working at the NSA they want to be very
very sure that your sole and only
loyalty is to this country I think it
should be the same thing with
politicians who are making the laws yeah
the ones who are in charge of things and
before anyone accuses me of racism
though I don't really care if you do
because that law that label has lost all
meaning these days but I would I would
say the same thing for anyone who
referred to another people or another
country as their people so find me an
example I know there were there were
what I was talking about this earlier
this morning there are people saying
well what about all the politicians who
are you know who side with Israel okay
well find me an example of a Jewish
politician in America talking about our
Israeli
people or my Israeli people and I would
have a huge problem with that too okay I
would have a huge problem with that but
I don't think you're gonna find that
actually now if you can find an example
of it then let me know but I'm not aware
of any example someone argued to me that
in context will tell Abe she refers to
the world and then she says our
Palestinian people so maybe she was
speaking from a global perspective and
she was saying like we're all one people
we're all each other's people or
whatever maybe that's what she was
saying I still have a problem with
American politicians speaking that way
in these global terms as if as if the
this the distinction of countries
doesn't matter that that troubles me
also because again you're an American
you're representative of the American
government and so you I think you need
to understand those distinctions and
respect them but that's not what's
happening here it's clearly not what you
say that's not what she means she's
talking about herself personally in fact
in her bio she identifies herself as a
Palestinian American and so it's no
wonder that she puts the Palestinian
first and we see how that works now but
if that is what she meant if she meant
it in a global way well does that mean
that Trump could talk about our Russian
people okay can you imagine how do you
think that would go over how do you
think it would go over if Trump sent out
a tweet saying talking about our Russian
people how would the Left react to that
they would I mean they would all they
would literally explode I think with
with rage there would be actual
explosions happening across the country
if that were to happen so so so no
obviously this is a problem it really is
and we cannot be so cowed by the racism
charges that we refuse to speak up about
something like this it is not okay for
the for a representative of the United
States Congress to identify her people
as people who do not live here it's just
not okay that is
extremely concerning to say the least
all right speaking of concerning videos
and/or concerning things and speaking of
loyalties lying elsewhere I should say
there's a watchdog a watchdog group
called the Middle East Media Research
Institute and they posted a video over
the weekend not not their own video but
they posted it to bring it to our
attention it's from a recent event at
the Muslim American Society Islamic
Center in Philadelphia and during this
event is there's a bunch of children
well let me just show you I'll just show
you we'll talk about it after look at
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay now if you're listening on
soundcloud or itunes and you didn't have
the benefit of subtitles and you didn't
understand the language then let me read
the Middle East Media Research
Institute's description of this video
from their YouTube page which described
what was going on there it says on April
22nd 2019 the Muslim American Society
Islamic Center in Philadelphia uploaded
a video of in Ummah Day celebration to
its Facebook page in which young
children wearing Palestinian scarves
saying this is what they were saying
glorious steeds call us and lead us to
the al-aqsa mosque the blood of martyrs
protect us take us oh ship s-- until we
reach our shores and crush the
treacherous ones flow o rivers of
martyrs a young girl read a poem
praising martyrs who sacrificed their
lives for Palestine and she asked will
Jerusalem be a hotbed for cowards
another young girl read will we defend
Palestine with our bodies we will chop
off their heads we will liberate the
sorrowful and exalted al-aqsa mosque we
will subject them to eternal torture so
so there you go that's what's happening
in America folks I you know I when I was
a kid I went to Christian events like
I'd go to Sunday School Vacation Bible
School I would go to and and you know
what we would do is we would we would
learn Bible stories we would maybe draw
a picture of know
we would sing songs like Jesus loves me
this I know for the Bible tells me so we
would do pageants uh we never recited
poems about chopping off the heads of
martyrs you know and we never talked
about crushing the treacherous ones
subjecting people to eternal torture
that so that was I guess it's just a
difference of style uh you know I don't
know and and by the way a totally
coincidental difference right it's just
it just so happens that this is a an
Islamic society where they've got kids
singing about cutting off people's heads
and just you never find that in with
Christian groups and it was just a
coincidence like that's we can't draw
any conclusions whatsoever
about the different religions because
they're exactly the same they're totally
equal and and how dare you think
otherwise all right here's another we'll
just keep it going here here's another
disturbing video to play for you on a
slightly different note but but only
slightly different not that different
actually Brian Sims is a state
representative in Pennsylvania somehow
he describes himself in his Twitter bio
as LGBTQ activist state representative
civil rights attorney college football
captain bearded RuPaul's Drag Race
fanatic and Little Mermaid enthusiast
and notice how he puts LGBTQ activists
before state representative so just like
Talib is a Palestinian before she's an
America well he's an LGBTQ activist
before he's the state representative and
the so the Little Mermaid fan he decided
that he wanted to harass and intimidate
an elderly woman and film himself doing
it and this goes on for now what I'm
going to show you here I'm not gonna
show you the whole video the actual
video goes on for like eight minutes of
this person harassing an elderly woman
I'm just gonna show you a clip of it
here it is hi everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I'm
once again out in front of
Planned Parenthood of southeastern
Pennsylvania it's not only in my
district it's the most heavily protested
Planned Parenthood I believe in the
country and today's protester now she is
an old white lady who's gonna try to
avoid showing you her face but the same
laws and luckily that protect her from
being out here also protect me from
showing you who she is and so my hope is
is that you'll donate $100 for every
extra hour that this woman is out here
telling people what's right for their
bodies let's have a couple questions for
you ma'am how many children have you
clothed today I'm sorry I missed your
answer how many children have you closed
today how about how many children have
you put shoes on their feet today have
you fed any children today or have you
just stood out in front of a Planned
Parenthood shaming people for something
that they have a constitutional right to
do
you can pray at home for children it's
probably the same place you could feed a
child but you're not instead you're out
here shaming people for something that
they have a constitutional right to do
who'd have thought that an old white
lady would be out in front of a Planned
Parenthood
telling people what's right for their
bodies shame on you shame on you for
hiding your face at the same time that
you're shaming other people again the
same laws that protect me protect you
and and that's okay you're allowed to be
here that doesn't mean that you have a
moral right to be out here shame on you
what you're doing here is disgusting
this is wrong you have no business being
out here yep disgusting so okay so the
The Little Mermaid theirs is doing a few
interesting things first he's sticking a
camera in a woman's face and literally
shaming her on the internet while
accusing her of shaming people
he actually she actually says he's a
shame on you for shame you're shaming
people shame on you I'm sure he's too
stupid to appreciate the irony but but
you and I can appreciate it anyway
also he keeps going on about clothing
and feeding children well there's a very
good chance that this woman who is both
brave and dignified by the way in her
response I'm and and that's how it is
the entire video she just she doesn't
run away but she she doesn't engage with
him she just stands there so I think a
very very brave and strong woman much
stronger than this person this
despicable cowardly Punk anyway but
there's a very good chance that she is
quite charitable in her private life I I
would be willing to bet that she gives a
lot to charity and that she has done a
lot to help kids I'd be willing to bet
that because that's the case with
pro-lifers despite what you hear from
parole board's they are lifers they only
care about babies before they're born
that is such utter non
I mean pro-lifers are constantly doing
things for for for children Pro it
shouldn't surprise you to learn that Pro
lifers love kids that's they they they
love human beings they love life that's
why were pro-life so this whole thing of
all you only care about babies were they
well soon as they're born you just leave
them that's just total now there's no
evidence for that that is based on
nothing that is just an empty accusation
it's something that pro-abortion people
say because it makes them feel more
comfortable it's what they want to
believe it would make them feel more
comfortable about their own evil sick
disgusting viewpoints if they could
convince themselves that oh yeah these
people over here they don't really care
about people they're just pretending um
well why I mean why do you why what do
you think that woman is their doing why
do you think that this elderly woman
decided to get up on a Saturday morning
and go to this guy what do you think
motivates that oh you really think it's
cuz she was she it's him it's hate for
she hates women she is a woman so she's
there because she hates women now you
know if if someone doesn't care you know
if it's true that pro-lifers don't
really care about life they don't care
about babies they don't care about one
but you know what they would do they
would do nothing they would just stay at
their home you don't get up on a
Saturday morning and go to a clinic and
subject yourself to that if you don't
actually care that's why they're there
they don't get anything out of this the
people who are at clinics what do you
think they get out of it for them
personally they don't get they're not
they're not making money off of it
they're subjected to harassment so I'm
sure they don't enjoy that there's
nothing in it for them they're only
doing it because they believe that
babies are being killed and they think
that that shouldn't happen so that's why
they're there don't project you as a pro
a boy as an empty soulless evil
apologist for murder don't project that
onto other because you don't care just
because you don't give a crap about
other people which is obviously
the case with this with this coward just
because you don't care doesn't mean that
something that everybody feels that way
yes you are self-absorbed and selfish
and all you care about is yourself
that's clear but that's not the case for
everybody there are people who actually
care about other humans and that's why
pro-lifers go to these clinics but all
of that is beside the point because the
idea that we can't oppose the murder of
a group of people unless we are also
feeding and adopting those people is
just ridiculous am I not allowed to
oppose the killing of the homeless
unless I've worked at a soup kitchen so
if someone proposed that we should go
and just eradicate all of the homeless
put them down like dogs in order to get
rid of the homeless problem and I stood
up and said no I'm opposed that would
you say but I don't see you working at
soup kitchens pipe down can I can I not
oppose the murder of toddlers unless
I've adopted a toddler
you know Andrea Yates drowned her five
kids in the bathtub her born children
I'm opposed to that I think that's
horrible are you gonna say oh well I I
didn't see you stepping up to adopt
those kids so shut your mouth it's just
it's such an absolutely idiotic talking
point and if you use that talking point
you're either a [ __ ] or you're lying
it's just there is no in-between option
there's no third option you you either
know that it's a stupid talking point
and you're using it because it's red
meat for for dumb pro-abortion people or
you're just really really stupid that
you can't see the problem with that and
how that line of thinking means that we
are not you you really can't oppose the
murder of anyone because what you're
saying is unless you personally are
stepping up to take care of this person
for their whole life you cannot be
opposed to their murder which means that
you know there are seven billion people
in the world I cannot take care of
almost any of them like I don't have the
III only have the resources to care for
a very very very very very small number
of those people and all those people
happen to live in my house right now so
what you're saying is I can't be opposed
to the murder of any of the rest of them
genocide whatever I can because I you
know what I'm not stepping up to care
for them so I guess yeah go ahead and
kill them you know I can't take Kate
whoever you are watching this if you're
pro-abortion I can't take care of you I
don't have the money for it or the
interest frankly you know so I guess I
can't be opposed to people killing you I
guess you know yeah go ahead
someone can just go ahead and kill you
and I can't say anything about it
because I'm not here giving you any
money right but mostly the big takeaway
here is that is that once again the
pro-abortion side is as always
vicious hostile shaming bullying
despicable while the pro-life side is
peaceful and non confrontational and
that's the way it is like 95% of the
time it's almost always that way every
once in a while you'll see the roles
reversed but not very often
and that's always alright there was a
report
well maybe we'll do that tomorrow there
was so maybe you've heard the latest
thing the latest trend is is I think it
called Seligman yes alig imme like
soullow it's when you marry yourself
when you fall in love with yourself and
marry yourself and that's the latest
trend so there was an article in a
British publication written by a woman
who married herself after after
shockingly she two of two of her
marriages fell through so she got
divorced twice
her marriages weren't working and then
she goes and marries herself I wonder
why those marriages didn't work out it's
it's a huge mystery right the kind of
person who's so self-obsessed that they
would marry themselves I wonder why it
didn't work in a marriage anyway
well maybe we'll talk about that
tomorrow there's more to be said about
it but I want to get to emails
especially because the first one I think
is very important this is from in Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com is the email
address Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Anna and I got several
emails like this so just reading one
says Matt I'd really enjoy your insight
on how Christians should react to the
death of Rachel held Evans obviously any
death is heartbreaking and we should
mourn with those who mourn but I find
some of the comments by Christian
leaders to be intriguing in the sense
that they seem to be glorifying her it
just feels very confusing I always
appreciate and trust your insight so if
you didn't hear the news over the
weekend Rachel held Evans a prominent
well-known liberal Christian writer died
and she died very suddenly unexpectedly
after I think she was react she had a
reaction to some medicine that she was
given for an infection kind of just
routine wrote to the hospital for an
infection and seemed like a routine
thing they gave her some medicine and
led to swelling in the brain and she
died if actually she sent a tweet when
she first checked into the hospital so
I'm in the hospital and she was joking
around about how she's gonna miss the
game of Thrones out and so to her it was
just a normal no big deal and then it
just was a freak
turns and then she ended up dying she
was 37 years old she had a husband and
two young children very very very sad
now I will say that she was I feel like
I have to say because it's kind of the
elephant in the room if you're familiar
with both of us then you probably know
that she was a critic of mine I was a
critic of hers critic is probably
understating it we were we were harsh
towards each other
very harsh and we were at polar opposite
extreme ends of things and so we were
both very critical of each other and
maybe that's why I got a lot of these
emails this weekend's asking what my
reaction is or how should we were you
how should we react to it
and I appreciate the email I appreciate
the question but to me the answer is
obvious how should we react to the
sudden death of a 37 year old mother of
two with sympathy and with morning and
with sadness that's all it is an
incredibly sad thing and I mourn her
loss I mourn for her family I pray for
them and we don't need to say anything
other than that that's all we need to
say there have been some Christians not
the majority by any means but but some
who decided to take the opportunity of
Rachel's death to express their
opposition to her theological views
there are Christians who it seems to me
and and not just because of this but
there are other examples well there are
Christians who have forgotten how to
just be human no no one is saying that
you have to suddenly agree with all of
our theological points of view just
because she tragically passed away
obviously not if you disagreed before
you still disagree and so everyone knows
that that doesn't change but when the
woman just died and her children are
still by her bedside saying goodbye and
she hasn't even been buried yet this is
not the time for criticism this isn't
this is not a forum
or a stage upon which you need to stand
and express your theological disputes
with this woman it's it's and I know
that the email or wasn't saying that I'm
Nam Nam I'm not talking to her I'm
speaking generally so just be a human
being be a human being for God's sake
that's all why is that so much for us
sometimes if you feel the need to say
more than just I mourn for her I'm sorry
for her family I'll pray for them if you
feel like you want to say more than that
if you feel like more needs to be said
more pontificating needs to be done and
it really doesn't but if you feel that
need then rather than giving a
theological lecture maybe think about
and talk about mortality and death
that's what I've been thinking about
this weekend you know here was a young
and healthy woman living her life making
plans for the future going about things
day to day like all of us and thinking
about you know the TV show she's gonna
watch but like like we all do just you
know you're looking forward to these
little things and just living your life
and suddenly just by some freak
occurence she's gone and that's it and
that's the end and that's gonna happen
all of us one day I mean one day you're
gonna eat your last meal one day you
will say I love you to your children for
the last time one day you'll fill up
your gas tank for the last time you'll
tie your shoes for the last time you'll
look at a bird for the last time I mean
all these things and you you probably
won't know that it's the last time that
you're doing those things when you're
doing them to you it will just be
Tuesday it'll just be a normal day and
that fact should mean something to us
shouldn't it
it should cause us to live differently
too to cherish life more to do more with
life to care less about stupid things
and more about important things because
we all know that if we are fortunate
enough to have some
before our death and were conscious and
and on our deathbed we all know that in
that moment we're gonna look back on so
much of what we did with our life and
regret it and feel like so much of that
was a waste and we're gonna look back on
so many of the things that we cared
about and worried about and all that
we're gonna say how stupid was I for
worrying about that it doesn't matter so
we all know that this epiphany will
occur to us yet for some reason we can't
live that way now and that's the thing
except for more momentarily so maybe
there's a death you're thinking about it
and in that moment when you reflect on
this stuff it does affect that change
but then we revert back to our old ways
of living and thinking and we go about
our day as if we're immortal as if death
can't come for us at any time so I don't
know maybe think about that or just be
sorry and mourn and express your
sympathy and and leave it at that
alright this is from Jennifer says I'm a
relatively new listener but your show is
now my favorite on the daily wire I'm a
fellow Catholic I wanted to get your
perspective on something that has been
bothering me my whole life
as a churchgoer what are your thoughts
on people who bring loud obnoxious and
distracting children to Mass for example
this past good friday during the evening
service there was a mother sitting
across from me whose toddler son would
shout baa every 10 seconds during the
entire first reading she made no effort
to try and quiet the child then in then
during the Liturgy of the Eucharist she
proceeded to let her child crawl back
and forth across the Pew in front of her
and then would flip the kid up and
around in the air playing with it
playing with it well him it is a little
strong she barely paid any attention to
the service and made my experience at
Mass and much less spiritual than I had
hoped I would like to think that when I
become a parent one day I will
immediately get up and step out if my
child becomes disruptive in church as a
father of three children what do you do
in these situations
yeah see this is a tough one with kids
at church and now I will say and I'm not
trying to put myself a pedestal here
that's just for me as a parent I am
hyper aware of my kids behavior and
their impact on people around them and
if they're being a distraction I'm hyper
aware of that and so in church the
moment they start making noise I'm
taking them out I'm taking her to the
back and and I'll bring them back in if
I can calm them down but I'm not gonna
ignore them it and it's the same if I'm
in a restaurant and you know my fight
the five year olds now are fine in
restaurants but two or three years old
is a tough age for a restaurant and so
when we're all there as a family if our
two-year-old is having a hard time and
he's crying or screaming or making a lot
of noise
I will pick him up and I'll bring him
outside and try to calm him down that's
and that's how I operate as a parent so
when I because the way I look at it is
yeah this is my kid but he's not
everyone else's kid and so there are
certain things that it annoyances that I
have to deal with as the parent of this
child but that doesn't mean that
everyone should have to deal with it so
that's that's how I've always tried to
operate and so I kind of feel the same
way you do Jennifer when I see these
parents who their kids are just being a
total distraction and in a disruption
and these parents like they don't even
notice I don't know as a parent I do not
understand that I kid I in some ways I
almost didn't my I'm almost wanna admire
it I'm jealous of it I wish I could be
that oblivious of my child and I wish
that I could care so little about how
annoying he is being to those around him
so I don't understand it but but some
parents are that way and so I don't
think that's the right thing you need to
as a parent you need to keep other
people around you in mind and realize
that yet you might be saying well I
don't want to have to get up and leave
charge because then I'm you know I'm
going to
out or I'm at a restaurant I don't want
to have time with my family I don't want
to have to get up and leave the
restaurant well yeah but that's your kid
that's your responsibility you can't say
well look I don't want to be
inconvenient so everyone else is gonna
have to deal with it no that's the wrong
thing it's your child that's your
responsibility I got my own kids to deal
with I shouldn't have to deal with yours
so this is a pretty simple thing
everyone deal with your own kid
don't make me deal with them so that's
on the one side right if your kid is
really being a disruption and a
distraction then you need to deal with
him get him out of the situation stop
forcing everyone else to have to endure
it because that's not fair
on the other hand we also have to be as
a society welcoming to children and and
and tolerant up to a point with the fact
that they are kids and there are some
non parents who I mean the minute you
walk into a restaurant with your family
and your young kids they're giving you
dirty looks and sometimes I'll be at
church and we'll have all the kids
sitting there and one of the kids will
make like one little noise or they'll
talk for two seconds and already there's
someone behind me shooting and whipping
their head back and giving a dirty look
so that's not right either on the other
end of the spectrum that's not right
uuuugh should we do need to have some
tolerance and patience with kids and
it's only up to a point because if a kid
is being so distracting and disruptive
that it's making them pop it impossible
for you to do what you came there to do
to appreciate the church service or to
enjoy your dinner well then yeah the
parent needs to do something but you
can't be completely intolerant and of
kids because they're part of society too
they're they're different from us they
operate differently they are a little
bit louder they're a little bit more
rambunctious that's just how they are
as kids that's just the way it is and so
we need to be understanding of that as
well and the last thing I'll say is
if you're in a situation if a parents in
a situation with it with a kid who's
being loud and crying and be disruptive
but it's a situation where they really
cannot take the kid out so let's say an
airplane for instance well then it
really does fall on everyone else to
just kind of deal with it and be patient
and be nice about it because there's
nothing the parent can do and I I've
been in situations with you know we've
we've taken our kids on on planes plenty
of times usually it goes fine and we
come prepared like we've got snacks
we've got toys we've got they I mean
we've got everything we can to try to
just bribe them to keep them silent at
least for that plane ride we try not to
operate that way as parents generally
but in a plane it's whatever you got to
do to keep them quiet do it right but
there's been a few times when one of the
kids just is having a bad time and they
start freaking out and screaming and
trust me as as the parent I feel way
more stressed out by it than you do as
even though I know it's annoying for
everybody else but there's nothing I can
do I can't take them out or 30,000 feet
in the air I'm doing everything I can to
keep them quiet it's not working
sometimes that just happens with kids
sometimes kids they just need to get out
of their system they want to cry they're
gonna cry
you sometimes there's nothing you can do
to stop it and so that's what I really
need everyone else to just bear with me
and and sort of be on my team even
though you don't know me or the kid so
that's how I would parse that finally
let's see from toxic white male Matt
Walsh it's inappropriate to call
naysayers of the Sandy Hook shooting
morons and brain-dead idiots when you
haven't had all the facts and evidence
presented to you and it's evident
through your arrogance on the entire
subject that you haven't with that said
I do respect your opinion however I
challenge you to watch the documentary
We Need to Talk About Sandy Hook on
YouTube which is a very detailed and
thorough investigation about the entire
Sandy Hook massacre comprised of
multiple youtubers and private
investigators if it doesn't change your
mind even just a little bit I will
personally donate $10 to your paypal
slash patreon and if it doesn't I'll
I'll still donate but if it doesn't ask
yourself this after you watch it is the
ruling class in the deep state capable
of orchestrating a false flag like a
sandy hook even if you believe it really
happened
PS and when Alex Jones changed his tune
and said that Sandy Hook really did
happen he'd confirmed the fraud that is
Alex Jones all right yeah I mentioned
this I don't remember what even remember
what the context was but I remember I
mentioned this last week the Sandy Hook
conspiracy and as I've said many times
it is a conspiracy believed by
brain-dead idiots and morons and a
conspiracy that was that was spread that
was invented and spread by people who
are worse than idiots people who were
who knew what they were doing and were
exploiting a tragedy for for publicity
do I regret using language that harsh no
I I don't at all I stand by it 100% I
mean this was a tragedy where dozens of
five and six-year-old children were
murdered and I can't to this day I
probably of all the tragedies that have
happened in American history
it leaves all the tragedies that have
happened while I've been alive all the
kind of national tragedies including
9/11
none of them affected me the way that
Sandy Hook did and still does even
though many more people died on 9/11 so
the death toll was much greater just the
specific targeting of five and
six-year-old kids was just and I heard
for the for the parents I cannot wrap my
head around that being a parent and
having that happen to your five-year-old
kid and how do you go on how do you live
I I just I can't even comprehend it so
to have people taking this very real
tragedy and turning
into some sort of cinematic story
turning it into some kind of game where
there's other secret agents and things
happening you know what just the best
thing I could say about someone who does
that is that you're stupid and there are
worse things I could say just stop there
are there are parents whose five and six
year old kids were shot in the head and
killed and all you can think is always a
conspiracy let's talk about the
conspicious whatsoever to claim that
that was conspiracy none and i've seen i
every time i talk about the Tipton's the
Sandy Hook nutters who come and say
we'll look at all this out I've looked
at the evidence there's none there is no
evidence there never was any this was
just invent you just came up with it in
your head and your whole thing's well
could they pull it off could they do it
a lot of people could do a lot of things
it doesn't mean that there's any
evidence that it actually happened just
oh they could have oh they could have so
that means that they did those two
things don't don't you understand that's
not the same just because you can come
up with a scenario wearing it's possible
that a certain thing could have happened
that doesn't mean that it actually did
happen to claim that something like that
happened you would need real solid
evidence you have none zero no evidence
and the the little bits of evidence that
you do have it doesn't even make it not
only is it did you is it invented and
and false but it doesn't even make any
sense like one of the pieces of evidence
that these Sandy Hook nutters would use
is they'll say they'll take a picture of
one of the children who died and then
they'll they'll find a similar looking
girl who was I think in this case was
one of the girls who died and then they
found a similar a similar looking girl
who appeared at some event with Barack
Obama and there's a it's a crisis actor
you see look she didn't really die it's
a crisis egg first of all not the same
girl and it's really obvious from the
picture second of all are you telling me
that this
this brilliant devious government that
could orchestrate this fake shooting for
no apparent reason that they could do
that but they they wouldn't think to get
a different crisis actor like they would
actually reuse the same person so
they're so brilliant that they can pull
off this whole staged hoax and fool
almost everyone yet they're also so
stupid that they leave these obvious
breadcrumbs that any person on on
YouTube can find in point though it's a
yawn you see clearly it's a hoax it just
makes no sense whatsoever and all the
pieces of evidence are just like that
we're number one that's not true but
second even if it were true if it's not
true but if it were then that would mean
that this government that these people
are so incompetent and foolish that
there's no way they could have pulled
this off in the first place
so you're trying to do both you're
saying on one hand there are brilliant
devious evil you know geniuses on the
other hand they're complete incompetent
oh the other one was they said oh you
see there's this if you look on Google
there was a story published about the
shooting before the shooting happened
look at that look at the Google time
stamp well number one time stamps on
Google are very often wrong happens all
the time where an article is published
but then the time stamp says it was
published like a day before it's just a
wrong times number two why would they do
that
if they're staging this hoax why would
they publish the article before it even
happened and what you're saying so the
New York Times is in on it too by the
way
so this is a far reaches as a conspiracy
involving that they were able to recruit
thousands of people across federal local
state governments media everyone's
involved yet they're so stupid that they
would publish the article before it even
happened you see you see you see a
problem there
so when you see something like that and
you say oh the time stamp is is a day
before whatever there are two possible
explanations one is that this is a
conspiracy involving thousands of people
branching across local state federal
government and many different media
outlets and it's a conspiracy involving
all these people yet they're so dumb
that for some reason they would decide
to publish the article beforehand that's
that's one explanation or the other
explanation is that time stamps are
wrong all the time and so this is just
an example of that which which which
explanation do you think is most
plausible what's the what's the
explanation it just makes the most sense
so anyway I'm not gonna continue on it
but yeah I have nothing but contempt for
that whole conspiracy theory I mean when
you're taking pictures of dead children
and you're accusing them of being actors
I mean as look if I a lead ate all of
the Sandy Hook nutters and they'd want
nothing then great I'm fine iliyan and
please if you're that kind of person I
perfectly fine with you not watching the
show or reading anything that I write I
really do not want to appeal to those
kinds of people so thanks for the email
anyway and we'll leave it there thanks
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed hey everybody's Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show you know
if you're on the right the big stories
happening right now the economy
Venezuela maybe Israel but if you're on
the left the big story is the story
itself the narrative who controls it and
how to silence anyone who disagrees I'm
Andrew Clavin we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show